people that are listed as attendees
rather than a panelist
if you uh if you would like to
participate ask questions
if you think there is a chance you would
might like to participate and ask
questions
and then yeah please raise your zoom
hands and uh
we will promote you to a panelist so you
can uh
just amuse yourself and ask questions
during the talk i think it worked well
so far and we might as well continue
with that
and uh then
and uh yeah if people feel comfortable
uh
i think uh rachel would love to see uh
your facial expressions as she is giving
the talk so feel free to turn on your
video
and and with that let's uh
and move on to uh the second part
the the the second part of this tutorial
by rachel who
uh really i think for you is a very
it's a culmination of a very long
journey of
trying to base uh trying to base
io and multilinear maps
yes struggle with them a lot
but happy ending in the end so let me
talk about the second part of this uh
tutorial on io from our foundation
assumptions
okay so definitely questions are very
much welcomed
i would love to interact with you during
the talk
um so let me start with highlighting
that what is the difficulty that we have
in constructing io
so as y'all has excellently summarized
basically what we want is a way to
encode
this function and then this encoding
should allow us to pick an
input of we like and evaluate it and at
the end of it get the output in clear
so there are two challenges in this task
one is that this evaluation of input x
has arbitrarily high degree
if i'm considering a general circuit if
f is implemented by a general circuit of
polynomial depth
the degree could be exponential and the
second difficulty part
is that we are not satisfied with
getting the output in any form of
encoding we literally want the output in
the clear
if we think about in a search in
cryptographic assumptions or things that
we know how to do
and things that resemble this form and
the only thing that we have
is bilinear maps and they will allow us
to encode some secret values
and then you can evaluate any degree two
polynomial on it
and you can actually extract the output
of this polynomial
in the clear if the output values are
small
and if we think about it that's
literally the only thing that we have
that resembles this
the the task that we have at hand
and therefore there is sort of like a
huge gap
between the degree that we can evaluate
and
the degree that we want to evaluate
unfortunately that as yell quickly
summarized that
pr prior works showed that if we
have a very simple certain random
generator that can be computed
using degree 2 polynomials we call them
degree 2 prgs
then we can evaluate it inside the
bilinear map in a secure way
then they showed that prior show that
with lots of other effort and a lot of
cryptographic techniques and we will be
able to bridge this gap
the issue is that we don't have degree
two prgs
we don't have some candidates
the best we have somewhat reasonable
candidates we have
have degree three but if you want to use
them then we will have to corresponding
have
a tri-linear map which we again don't
have
so the ideas in the more recent works
is not just in the gls but already has
been alluded to
in prior works is to use a new notion
which is the degree 2.5 prgs
and matchingly try to evaluate the
degree 2.5 computation using bilinear
map
then we can again use a prior technique
to get to io so what is this degree 2.5
computation
as mentioned is that it's a computation
that it's input you can think about it
as a two re
function that the input contains a
public input and a secret input
and we allow constant degree on the
public input
and the only degree two in the circuit
input
and this is in general what we call as a
degree 2.5 computation
and indeed we show that actually when i
say we
doesn't necessarily mean jls actually we
means
as a community because a lot of
techniques were developed by fireworks
and we as a community know how to
evaluate such computation using
bilinear map through this concept called
partially hiding functional encryption
and the degree 2.5 prg has the formal
name of structure seed prg
and combining these two we can get io
so this is the uh leads to the template
of this
second part of the tutorial that using
bilinear map we have partial hydrogen
functional encryption
and we can implement this degree 2.5
structure c the prg
using lpn over larger fields and the prg
in
nc0 and we'll need one more additional
two which is a homomorphic encryption
for very simple
nc 0 functions implemented from lw
putting these three things together we
will get the functional encryption
for nc 0 and this is the semi-succinct
functional encryption for nc 0 that yao
was talking about
and from there we can bootstrap to fe
for polynomial
size circuits and that was shown to be
equivalent to io
with a sub-exponential security laws
so the focus of this part is to show you
how to use those intermediate objects to
get to functional encryption for nc 0
and then i usually is going to show you
how to build structure
seed prg so
i am not going to throw at you
the definition of all those intermediate
object or at once rather i will try to
develop ideas
step by step and introduce those objects
along the way
so hopefully it's clear that what's the
purpose of each of the object
and to start i will first define
functional encryption and homomorphic
encryption quickly
and by contrasting those two primitives
we'll get
initial ideas for how to approach
functional encryption
and then later on i will introduce these
other objects
all right and so homomorphic encryption
here we look at the secret key version
and what it allows us to do is that we
can encrypt an
input using since we consider circuit
key
using both the master property key you
can think about the master property just
as the public parameters
and the secret key and sometimes i
already know the cipher text
with this parenthesis of x indicating
that the encrypted input is
x and i will use the subscript as to
indicate what is the secret key involved
in this cipher text
sometimes i may not uh append the
parenthesis of x
and the little s in the subscript so
this is just a convenient notation for
me
and the magic of homophobic encryption
is that given any function
we can actually turn a ciphertext of an
input x
into a ciphertext of the output f of x
this is formally captured as the
homomorphic evaluation procedure
which makes use of only the master
property the function
and the ciphertext and have no knowledge
about the secret key whatsoever
and when we decrypt this output
ciphertext
resulted from the homomorphic evaluation
procedure what we get
is f of x the output
and the security guarantee is the just
like a vanilla
semantic secure encryption scheme that
it says without knowledge about the
secret key
which should be as here the cipher text
really reveals no information about the
input
so even if one can homophobically
evaluate arbitrary functions
everything still sits inside encryption
both the input and the output everything
remains hidden
and this is formalized through
indistinguishability where we require
ciphertext
of arbitrary inputs to remain
indistinguishable
the functional encryption is also
enabling
computation over encrypted inputs
however
differently that it will allow the
evaluator to obtain the output in the
clear
to obtain output in the clear the
evaluator needs additional help
and in particular that it needs to
obtain what we
call as a partial decryption key or
functional key
which needs to be generated using the
master secret key
and the magic is that the decryption
using this partial decryption key
does not give you the encrypted input
as is but rather give you the encrypt
give you the output of the function
evaluated on the encrypted input
now the security property is that given
a secret key
the only information that is revealed
should be the function
and the output of the function alone and
all other information about the input
beyond what can be inferred by the
output should remain headed
and this in the indistinguishability
language requires that for any input
that yield the same output with respect
to the
function should have cipher text
that are indistinguishable even when
we give away this partial secret key for
encrypting rachel um i always also used
to
when i described functional encryption
used the term crippled key but then i
thought maybe it's not a nice term and i
i don't know if anyone has found like a
nicer team
i don't know if hobel's key is there any
uh
nicer than we call it functional key
yeah that doesn't say immediately
immediately convey the fact that it's
less than that it's a street yeah
challenged challenge challenge
okay sorry for the interaction no that's
a very good question yeah we still have
better names
okay function only key or something like
that yeah so if if we come up with some
i would i would love to use it
so as we as a yo has already mentioned
functional encryption turns out to be
extremely powerful so powerful that
functional encryption for just computing
nc0 circuit
functions is already implying io if we
assume lw
and the prg in nc0 and here we require
the efficiency requirement on this
functional encryption
is that we just need the cipher text
size
to be linear a good pattern obviously
the server will have to depend on the
length of the input
we will also allow it to depend on the
length of the output of the function
and just that the dependency is
sublinear
we want the ciphertext to be just
slightly shorter
than the output of the function and here
i'm using this slightly weird notation
big
o of lambda which means that i will
ignore all constant factors but also all
polynomial factors in the security
parameter
all right so
now our goal is to just realize this
functional encryption for nc 0
with sublinearly compact ciphertext
and when we think about these two
primitives we put them side by side
functional encryption and homophobic
encryption they definitely share
the the aspect that they allow
computation over the encrypted input
the only difference is that homophone
encryption
everything remains hidden if the
evaluator has no idea about the secret
key
and with the sacred key the almighty
secret key then all information is
revealed
so this has this like classical crypto
cryptography guarantee of zero or one
right either you get our information or
you'll get no information at all
and there's nowhere in between and your
functional increase and for this type of
security guarantee we actually are
pretty good at it
and indeed that from learning with
errors we can get homework encryption
for all polynomial size functions
however we are pretty bad at
implementing the other type of guarantee
which is about revealing part of the
information
hiding the rest and that's exactly the
goal of functional encryption
they want to be able to have this crypto
key or or partial key or functional key
since that reveals the outputs and the
height
yet everything else is hidden so this
kind of a half
information review is what is difficult
and essentially the best we know is to
use bilinear parent groups
to get functional encryption for
computing degree two polynomial in zp
okay and so there's a huge gap in what
we can achieve when we can handle
when it comes to these two different
primitives
even though that at a high level they
share a lot of similarity
so then the rationale for us
towards constructing functional
encryption really stems from this
comparison
and we observe that if we have a way to
decrypt the homomorphic encryption
output
ciphertext in a secure way that reveals
only the output
but nothing else then that's essentially
functional encryption
but how can we decrypt in a secure way
that reveals only the output but nothing
else
well that's paradoxical right that's
exactly what functional encryption
allows you to do
so then the hope is that perhaps doing
decryption is just simpler
then at least we achieve kind of
bootstrapping in terms of functionality
that
use a simpler fee to get a more complex
fe
so this is the initial idea that towards
constructing a functional encryption key
functional encryption scheme for nc 0
we're going to actually just use a
homomorphic
encryption scheme to encrypt the input
use a secret key that is sampled
fresh at random and each time we
generate a functional encryption
ciphertext
and now we're going to use hopefully a
simpler functional encryption scheme
for exactly the decryption task meaning
that we hope
that the secret key and the ciphertext
when we decrypt
it will reveal exactly the output of the
function on x so let's
start with developing this idea by just
coming up some version of this function
h and some encrypted input that will
achieve this goal
the most straightforward way to do it is
to let the function h
get input which is a homomorphic
ciphertext itself together with the
secret key
then the function h shall first do the
homophobic evaluation procedure
to get a ciphertext encrypting the
output
f of x then since it also has the
secret key of the hd scheme then you
just need to decrypt
right decrypt the output ciphertext and
that gives exactly y
so if this fe bar this scheme
used for fhe decryption is indeed a
secure one
then it's include its security guarantee
directly guarantees
that only the output y is revealed and
or other information in particular the
secret key of the homophobic encryption
remains hidden and then the home of
encryption will hide at the input x
okay the problem is that we want
we're using a functional encryption key
encryption scheme to implement a
functional including scheme
so there better be something to gain and
again we hope for
was that this function h that needs to
be evaluated should be simple
should be in particular simpler than
function f
however this is absolutely not the case
because the homophobic
evaluation of function f cannot be
simpler than function f itself
and furthermore that decryption
algorithm of
any encryption scheme that is mentally
secure cannot be too
simple right for example it cannot be
linear in fact they cannot have constant
degree
it cannot have a small locality so on
so what are we doing turns out that both
of those difficulties can actually be
handled
if we plug in good tools in particular
we will use a homomorphic encryption
scheme
where the decryption is almost linear
but not exactly linear
and the second is that if we observe the
structure of this computation
in h it has two phase of computation
and the first phase of homomorphic
evaluation actually operates completely
on public information
it operates on f and it operates on each
ct
both of them are public there's no need
to hide them
on the other hand that what are sacred
and needs to be hidden is exactly the
homophobic ciphertext secret key
and the decryption procedure the
computation of the decryption
needs to be hidden so the ratio now is
that
shouldn't we only count those complexity
on secret inputs
you know computational public
information who cares
and indeed this can be realized using
this tool called
partially hiding functional encryption
so next
let me introduce those two tubes and now
we'll come back to instantiate this
scheme all right
so partially hiding functional
encryption is exactly meant for
evaluating those type of functions
that have two inputs and the one part
the first part of the input
is public and we do not care about
hiding and the second part of
input is what we care about hiding
and the syntax of this scheme is
basically the same as the syntax of a
normal functional encryption
then when we obtain a secret key for
a partial key for function h decryption
reveals
each evaluated on both parts of the
input
however security says that given the
secret key
only the output of the function and the
public input is revealed we don't care
about hiding the public
input and i'm going to use a slightly
different language which is the
simulation language to formalize this
security intuition
then we require that given the master
public key the secret key for function h
and the cipher text these three things
can be simulated by a simulator who has
only the output and the public input a
okay so this is just a slightly
different way to formalize the security
we can also equivalently formalize it
using distinguishability
on definition and these two notions are
actually
uh equivalent rachel is the way to think
about it that
you are relaxing the security
requirement in a sense that's saying
you're
allowing to uh leak a and
that enables you to use a function age
that are more complicated
in their a part than would have been
otherwise
that's exactly what the intention is
and indeed we show that i know we show
i'm always confused when i say we i'm
minor community
the currency shows that we can implement
that's the scholarly we the scholarly
yes you
and the listeners and in the community
at large exactly yeah
we show that using bilinear maps we can
actually have partially hiding
functional encryption
for degree 2.5 polynomials and those
polynomials
can be written as the quadratic
polynomial
over x over the x the secret part of the
input
and the coefficient on those quadratic
monomials
depends on the public input a and this
dependency could
have constant degree so this
form of polynomial h we call them
degree 2.5 more formally they have
constant degree of
a and degree 2 in x
and because of the fact that the degree
on x is really only 2
and it's not too surprising that we can
actually implement it using bilinear
maps
and we can have a public key partially
highly functional encryption for this
type of polynomial
and they have simulation security
and they have actually really good
compactness the ciphertext size
only span depends linearly on the input
length and has nothing to do with the
output length whatsoever
there is a little bit of a star here
that i need to
explain a caveat is that these uh
schemes only have correctness when the
output of this polynomial h
is small and what do i mean by small
means that they are polynomial
magnitude and though the function
and the polynomial magnitude is a lot
smaller than the size of the modulus
which is
sub-exponential you can think of the
modulus as sub-exponential large
okay and this exactly stems from the
fact that we're using bilinear pairing
groups
and the intuition is that we essentially
do the computation
inside the exponent of the bilinear
parent group and in order to extract the
outputs
out in the clear we can only do so if
the output
happens to be small
and a quick note is that if we want to
get a public key partially highly
functional encryption we actually use a
slightly different
assumption over the bilinear parent
group
in the paper we use the secret key
version which is also sufficient
then that can be used be based on the
sxdh assumption
we use
okay so this is the first tool which is
the partially hiding functional
encryption the second tool as mentioned
is a homophilic encryption based on lw
i'll quickly go over
a very very vanilla version of
homophobic encryption
that's sufficient for our scheme just
for completeness
okay so we build it out of home
out of lwe assumption we know that rwe
is
um postulates that if we get
a public matrix a and c which is
a times s which is a short unknown
vector
and adding some noise which are small
gaussian nausea
noises the joint distribution of a comma
c
is pseudorandom that they are
indistinguishable from completely random
elements from dp
from this assumption we can immediately
implement a secret key encryption scheme
and for this assumption to hold it's
important to note that to keep in mind
that
at the alpha at all cost we need to make
sure that
the unknown s prime and the noise are
hidden
if we want to hide the vector x what we
can do that are boolean
what we can do is just to add it to the
c component
and to make sure that we can separate
the x away from the noise e
we will just multiply the noise with two
to make the noise even and the rw
assumption with even noise is still hold
as long as the modulus is odd
and as such we immediately get a
ciphertext
the c component is the ciphertext
encrypting x
and we can view the public matrix as
something the crs
or in the public key and the secret key
is unknown as prime
one neat thing is that the ciphertext is
actually rather compact
right so the size is linear in the
length of the input
and this very basic encryption scheme
has only one ciphertext security
and why because we are kind of using the
public matrix a
which means that the unknown as prime
which is the secret key
can only be used once per the lwe
assumption
but that's enough and it has one
ciphertext security and that's already
enough for
our purpose of building functional
encryption for nc 0.
the most important property of this
encryption scheme is that
it has almost linear decryption when we
want to decrypt
all we want to do is to multiply s prime
with the problem matrix a and subtract
it away from
c and that linear operation already give
us the encrypted input
x perturbed by some even noise and now
we can recover
the x by doing mode two
but the important thing is that with
just a linear operation
we already get almost an encrypted input
albeit with some noise
so how do we add a homomorphism to this
very basic encryption scheme
well that basically involves looking at
the almost linear decryption equation
and let's think that if you want to
evaluate the an nc0 function
well that function first of all can be
always written as a degree d polynomial
in gp
why because every boolean function with
a locality
d can be written as a multi-linear
polynomial
with degree d at most d in any field zp
now we can just evaluate this polynomial
f on both sides of the equation
and on the right hand side we see that
every component
every output element can just be
viewed as consisting of f of x
together with some even noise right and
we lump together all those monomials
and they involve at least one term of e
as the new even noise e prime and has
the right hand side
is just f of x plus two times some new
noise e prime
the left hand side because function f
has a degree d it can always be
rewritten in a format
into some matrix cf that depends on
a and c yeah so so just
make make sure if you could go back for
a second i just want to make sure that i
uh understand the
what you're doing you are basically
saying that
because f only has constant degree if
you
expanded out all the parentheses then
you will have a
basically f of x plus a a constant
number of terms that
all have two in them and a bunch of
other stuff as well
and and those are not going to be too
big because
or two non-sparse because there is only
constant number of them
exactly that's exactly what i'm saying
yeah here we're talking about lwe so
the exact property we want from e prime
is that they're small
and i'll note that again in the next
slide
thank you for mentioning that yeah and
on the left hand side
basically we can write this degree
decomposition
on a comma c multiplied with s
as being the multiplication between a
matrix cf
that depends on a and c and all the
degree d monomials
in s and we do we notate like denote the
order degree d monomials in s
in a vector in this like tensor notation
which is sort of like you tensor this
vector d times with itself
and that definitely contains all the
degree monomials in it
so the left and the right hand side
equal and this
gives us a very desirable new decryption
equation
which is still almost linear and on the
right hand side is exact
the left-hand side we can view this
matrix cf
as the homomorphic evaluation output
ciphertext
which in particular has degree d in a
comma c which is original ciphertext
its dimension is rather large we're
really doing brute force expansion
so its dimension is going to be at least
the
secret key dimension to the d but as
long as you know we're computing
constant degree function this is really
fine it's
still trackable on the right hand side
we still get the outputs perturbed by
some small even noise
because this e prime is degree d in the
original noise e
and the input x and both of them are
very small
and we note that because it depends on x
and e
at all costs we must hide them but
the fact that it's small is going to
help us to
hide them okay so these are the two
tools that we're going to use and let's
see that when we plug them back into
this
framework for constructing a fifa and c0
what happens
whether we solve the problem so the idea
now is that we're going to use exactly
this single homophobic encryption
where the cipher text is a times s prime
plus 2 e plus
x and the secret key can only be used
once this s
prime and the noise are going to be just
sampled fresh
at each encryption time the public
matrix a
is going to be sampled once and
contained in the master public key
now the simple fe scheme we're going to
instantiate using this partially hiding
functional
encryption scheme for degree 2.5
polynomials
and it allows us to encrypt a public
input
which is the homomorphic encryption
ciphertext
and the sacred input and we're just
going to include all degree d
monomials in the secret s
now the function h that we compute
first does a homomorphic evaluation
which used to compute that the big
matrix cf
and then decrypt this cipher text
now decryption is almost linear meaning
just do multiplication with all degree d
monomials in
s and that already gives us the output
perturbed by some even noise
the good part is that we start with
using these tools in order to make sure
that the complexity of this function h
is not too high and we observe that we
achieve this goal
because the public part of the
computation
is only degree d and the secret part of
the computation is just degree one so
obviously it's
the overall this whole thing is degree
two point five
we also note that the compactness is
pretty good at the moment
because the homomorphic ciphertext is
linear in the importance and all degree
monomials
in the sacred eyes you know it does blow
up very big
but since the secret of the lwe is just
you know security parameter lens so it's
still security polynomial in the
security parameter
and now we can tolerate and and i hope
other people can also
chime in or not i just have this always
all the question
why do we think of this as 2.5 rather
than 1.5
uh what's the kind of calculation like
you
you might say okay it's a linear secret
so if we just say
everything public is 0.5 why don't we
think of it as a 1.5 degree
yeah you're completely right at the
moment it is 1.5
and the moment is 1.5 yeah i'm just
doing an upper bound analysis
but later on we will see that 2.5 is
necessary
okay everything is great except for this
bug
of reveal of the noise
which is a very annoying security bug
as as we mentioned that at all cost we
must hide the noise because it depends
on x and
e and if you think about it even if
we don't know how to exactly recover x
from e prime
if we want to apply the lwe assumption
uh we need to make sure that e prime is
hidden otherwise
as soon as some information about the e
is revealed i cannot
apply the algebraic assumption
well normally that in the homophobic
evaluation decryption we got rid of e
prime by doing more too
but that is actually a very complex
computation in c1
so we cannot stick it inside the
function h
fortunately as we said the saving grace
is that e-prime is small
it's polynomially bounded so there is a
much more efficient way of hiding it
which is just to add some larger noise
to it to flood it
and the neat thing is that if the
flooding noise
is large enough large enough comparing
with the magnitude of e prime itself
then we know that the statistical
distance between row plus e prime
and the row is is able to be bounded by
one over lambda
okay so this means that e prime is
partially hidden once we add the row to
it
partially hidden because the statistical
distance between
rho plus e prime rho is not negligible
here it's 1 over lambda which is
normally insufficient for cryptographic
purposes but at least it's
something it's partially hidden and
why are we kind of only looking at 1
over lambda's physical distance but
rather negligible distance or just
whack up the magnitude of rho large
enough
we can actually make the statistical
distance negligible
well that's because of that annoying
star that we had
on the partially hiding of e we can only
extract the output
meaning the whole thing two row plus y
plus two e prime
in the clear if they are polynomially
bounded
okay so if rho is polynomially bounded
we at the best can achieve some inverse
polynomial statistical distance
and that's why but nonetheless
this give us something so now our new
purpose
is to try to use h to compute y plus 2 e
prime plus 2 rho with some smudge noise
the next question is where do those row
come from well
we need as many rows as the lines of y
well one naive thought is well and and
those rows must be
secret right if they are public then
clearly they don't hide anything
so since we need to hide it why not just
put it in the secret part of the
partially hiding fee
well this is still satisfied the degree
requirements gives us some partial
security
but it completely kills compactness
because we need
as many rows as the length of the output
y
and this naturally leads to the idea of
using a prg
right one we need many many randomness
and we don't have
we don't want to use so many true random
coins we use a prg
right then if we have a prg we can just
only encode
the seed of the prg in the secret input
of the partially hiding fee
and inside the function h we're going to
first expand the prg to get those margin
noise raw
and then add it to the output
for this to work and we really need a
very very simple prg because
function h is so simple we need to keep
function h
simple and this leads to
our keys to the random object that
amit mentioned the structure see the prg
later maybe small question yeah
i'm not sure that it's very defined but
but you said that you have some
some right the problem was that you have
some leakage on the noise right you can
smudge it partially but you still have
uh you still
can learn some information so okay so
you generate pseudo-random noise but you
could kind of
try to like we have all sorts of
techniques to to amplify
hardness or you know to immunize
encryption skins
so couldn't you use like a maybe secret
sharing based tools in order to do these
kind of things okay
to say okay i i lost some entropy but
still it's okay because the things are
hidden
yeah you're 10 steps ahead of me and
that's
eventually what have to happen because
what i'm presenting now we're
at best to give you partial security so
after we get the partially secure
functional encryption for nc 0 we will
need to at some point bootstrap amplify
the security back to full before we can
get io
that's a good question yeah
okay but for now that uh let's stay
satisfied and content with even just
getting weakly secure functional
encryption for nc 0.
now coming back maybe
again like the point the response to
benny is that yes benny is right and you
could do it
but the inverse polynomial leakage was
not the reason why you had
all these uh issues so far the reason
why you had to work so far is not to get
to avoid the universe polynomial leakage
but
rather to do to get compactness yes
yes to get compactness yeah
or or right it's a it's a combination of
different technical limitations like one
is that we only have partially hiding
and v
on from bilinear maps and then bilinear
map only allow me to get
small outputs out of the exponent and
the way that we handle computation is by
homomorphic evaluation
and that we need to hide the noise and
we can only hide noise
by adding polynomial large noise so
it's it's like a little bit i don't know
i mean hopefully there are other ways of
doing it
but we're sort of really working under
the constraint of different primitives
all right so when we come back to this
sicilian random object
that a classical definition of prg has
three algorithms it allows us to first
sample a function index
and this function index you can view it
as all the information that is made
public
right and then it allows us to sample a
seed
for a particular function index and
finally given the function index and the
seed we can evaluate the output
so we want the polynomial stretch
meaning that the length of the seed is
really
sublinear in the length of the output
and
the prg that we evaluate is really the
evaluation algorithm
with the function index coded inside
so normally that we want to make sure
that given the function index the output
of the prg
is indistinguishable from a truly random
string of the same length
and now this is really so far the only
slide this is really the most
vanilla like crypto object ever one of
the most
vanilla object but we add this very
non-trivial requirement on it
we want this prg to be simple and
simplicity for us means that evaluation
algorithm for any function index i
is computable by a low degree polynomial
in fact
we need a degree 2.5 polynomial
but in general that this is an open
question that people have looked at
and there had been quite an extensive
line of work trying to minimize
what's the degree for evaluating prg
what is relatively on solid ground are
degree
constant prgs they can be instantiated
using gold rush
prg and c0 and so far that now we can
ask
can we what's what's the smallest
constant that we can have
for degree 2 we have no candidate
and we just want slightly
stronger slightly more complex
computation of degree 2.5
and to handle degree 2.5 we have to
change
on the syntax of the prg slightly
now we allow the siege to contain a
public part which is the public seat
and the secret part we call the secrecy
and the indistinguishability security
now says that
even given the public seat the output of
the prg
shall be pseudorandom now degree 2.5
means that
this evaluation can be done by a
polynomial
that have constant degree on public cp
and
only degree 2 in the secrecy dash over
the boolean cube
so at the first glance that it's strange
that why does this
public see the help at all in fact our
instinct
for having something that's public is to
just fix that
public value or some point some point
well at random ones and fix it and reuse
it right
why not we can just sort of put p this
public seed into the function
index and then it will come back
converted into just a prg in the secrecy
why doesn't that work that doesn't work
because that
we allow the puppy seed and secrecy to
be joined to the sample to buy this
seed something algorithm and it can be
arbitrarily correlated
in fact in the instantiation the public
seed can be viewed as an encryption of
the secrecy
as such if we fix the public seed
there is actually it's actually
computationally difficult
intractable to sample the corresponding
secrecy
and that's why the public seed is not
reusable at all
and we should absolutely utilize this
fact to instantiate
such degree 2.5 prg so so maybe
okay so that that's maybe like a very
good way i mean
maybe the way to think about it is
really that the public seed is a
function
of the secret seed in some sense it's a
so so so it's more like
um you you're licking some partial
information
so rather than maybe thinking of it as a
seed maybe it's better to think of it as
a leakage
and and as long as uh you your
calculation
is only degree two uh in the things that
are not leaked and you're allowed to
and and this thing is still secure even
after the leakage then it is
then it's fine yeah you can do it that
way
then we want the leakage to not hurt the
in some sense the pseudo randomness of
the of the prg
but somehow the expansion but the
expansion you're computing with respect
to both
the leakage and and the seed right i
mean so in that sense this
interpretation is leakage is somehow
you do want to think about this c
because the expansion is with respect to
the
joint length if i understand correctly
from a meets talk that's right
so maybe the leakage should be also
short which is not an
assumption for leakage so you want to uh
you want to make sure that
there is a small amount of
so you somehow you could say you have a
pseudo-random generator and it
works in two steps uh one step could be
pretty complicated but all it does is
produce some
some some intermediate state that is
then leaked out and it's not too big and
then
there is a simple computation yes yeah
um right and then the fact that the
length of the public scene needs to
count is exactly because
it's not reusable right so every time
when i generate i'm generating two parts
together and then
none of them is reusable then their
length has to count
towards compactness
okay so this is the key to the renault
object that we were built
so previous work has already had this
notion embedded inside and not
explicitly formalized as in jls but the
ideas were already there
but however they used sort of new
assumptions to instantiate it
and in the new work of gls that we show
that if we assume
lpn over larger fields we can actually
convert
any prg in nc 0 into our degree 2.5 prg
albeit that it will only have weak
security
okay so i'm for now not telling you what
is the weak security
but let's pretend that we actually
really have full security structure seed
prg
and come back to this paradigm to
complete it
so now with this degree 2.5 prg
what we can do is that we can now
uh encrypt the public seed in the public
part
of the parties hiding fee and the
secrecy in the secret part of the
partially hiding fee
and the function h can now first
evaluate
this degree 2.5 prg to get
random bits and then lump together the
random bits to get
slightly larger smudge noise and then
finally add as much noise to the output
to hide the e prime because of the fact
that the prg has degree 2.5 now we see
that this function h has degree 2.5
and we still have compactness as we
desire
because now the length of the ciphertext
increase
by the size of the seed but since the
size of the seed is sublinear
and the partially hiding fee has really
really good compactness
of all the size of the ciphertex is
sublinear in the length of the output
now let me quickly walk you through the
security
security wants to say that given the
public key one secret key
and the cipher text the only thing
revealed is why
and this involves proving that for any
two input x 0 and x 1
their cipher text remain
indistinguishable given the public key
and the partial decryption key
and we will only be able to prove the
weak security
and we'll see that the weak
theoretically comes from two sources
and the weak security means that the
indistinguishability
the distinguishing gap is only upper
bounded by one over lambda
instead of negligible so starting from
this distribution we care about
for some particular input x b
we observe that the master property
secret key and
the cipher text are all belonging to the
partially hiding fee
and it has a simulation security so we
can simulate these components
using the output the output computed
by the partial height of v is exactly y
plus 2 e
prime plus 2 rho and here in this
distribution raw is generated
using the structure seed prg then next
we can immediately use the structure
seed prg security
to swap role to truly random truly
random
smudge noises and then by the
statistical arguments that we see that e
prime plus rho prime
is statistic close to e prime itself
without e prime
uh okay so i am wrapping up this is the
last slide yeah
is this this is close to rho prime
itself
uh except that we have now a distinction
gap of one over lambda
and at this hybrid we observe that
nothing about the homophobic encryption
ciphertext is revealed not the secret
key not the noise nothing
and hence we can swap xb to encryption
of zero
and finally when we say that we only
have weak
security for the degree 2.5 prg we mean
that the student randomness they achieve
also has distinction gap upper bounded
by one over lambda
rather than negligible but this does not
change in the statement of the lemma
and that's the end of my part i have
shown you that
how we managed to get fu for nc 0 with
only weak security
and this using the existing bootstrap
can give us fe4p
with weak security so we'll need one
more additional step as manny and the
boss
discussed about of security
amplification from fe4
p from weak to full security then we can
get io
okay and i will leave the
leave the other details and uh i usually
next to talk about
construction of degree 2.5 percent
thank you so much rachel so any
questions
maybe uh people maybe we can take
uh let's see how how does the schedule
look like
uh just so we have um so uh
edition yeah so maybe we can take
a a five-minute break and i just can
start in uh
say let's say seven minute break so i
usually you start at the
um 11 30. that's fine yeah
sure yeah uh especially i have a
question
uh could you summarize the function that
was being hidden by
phfe so it it had the description of the
initial hg
yes and
that's this slide i believe
it has the so the function the passion
hiding does
is the first homomorphically evaluate
the nc 0 function f
over homomorphic cycle text get the
output ciphertext then it does the prg
expansion
to get a bunch of random bits
and then it needs to get smudging noise
right and so from the bits
to largest margin noise we can just kind
of do
multiply with powers of two to get the
right magnitude of the noise
and then finally you decrypt plus the
noise
plus the same one so the f here is
basically the decryption of the he
yes it did both the homomorphic
evaluation of hc
and the decryption and also added this
much noise
three tasks
okay okay
any other questions yes please
there are no more questions let's take a
five minute break and then
11 30 i i usually start and i use let's
try to finish uh
just just 10 minutes after time so we we
still have uh people still get a chance
to stretch and they're not
definitely yeah sorry for going over
time yeah thank you very much
that's fine it's not that bad if we go a
little bit over time
so let's see each other everyone in five
minutes